on tourne au par un peu vieux jeu quoi
un peu de 14 il ne trouva pays c'est à
dire ils pensent que les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui pensent qu'à s'amuser ils
ont pas de soucis quoi ils pensent qu'à
courir ces jeunes skieurs sont d'esker
un peu inhabituel non ce n'est pas dans
leur style
il faut chercher ils sont différents
c'est parce qu'ils sont ici chez eux ce
sont de jeunes paysans de la montagne et
ça n'empêche pas la plupart d'entre eux
de faire comme les citadins le ski le
dimanche pour s'amuser bon depuis l'âge
de 5 ans parce que je tenais ce que ça
vous plairait de faire du petit bout de
vie est parfaite je pourrais tu viens
pas moniteur la sco ce que je lui
portais l'école la station était pas
encore roman c'est pas salé partir du
bon et du mauvais et toi pourquoi tu
deviens pas moniteur auguste davantage
et j'ai vu que je pouvais arriver un peu
plus arriver un peu plus pour jets
auguste est arrivé un peu plus loin
c'est d'abord sortir de ces hautes
vallées ou des siècles durant des
générations de jets ont été bloqués par
la neige pendant six mois d'hiver et le
reste du temps par la pauvreté
et puis il ya 10 ou 15 ans tout a changé
tous les enfants ou presque sont allés
au collège ou au lycée puis en faculté
pour certains puis il y a quelques
années tout a changé une nouvelle fois
des hélicoptères se sont posés au sommet
des montagnes et ont débarqué les normes
matérielles des stations de sports
d'hiver
et c'est ainsi que dans le haut chanceur
le point d'équilibré qui était haussière
dans le bas de la vallée près de la
route s'est trouvée transporter 400
mètres plus haut à merlette là où sont
les pistes les remontées la station
et les jeunes gens qui ont maintenant
entre 15 et 20 ans ont vécu leur
première enfance dans une montagne fermé
préserver du reste du monde et ils
vivent leur adolescence dans une
montagne transformé par le grand cirque
des sports d'hiver
parmi les jeunes de saint martin dans la
haute vallée des belleville
nous avons trouvé j'ai clément géo gus
qui n'a aucun lien de parenté avec lui
et j'ai michel qui est le frère de
jacques clément si bien sûr de
cultivateurs nous voilà concédant à
l'envers qu'est ce qui n'est pas fils ou
fille le cultivateur
j'étais à paris et qui parmi vous à
l'intention de de continuer le métier de
ses parents c'est à dire des
cultivateurs des fusées il a peur du
pire
donc j'ai l'impression que la ville est
limité
non sérieusement il ya pas un d'entre
vous qui accueille l'intention de
reprendre l'exploitation de ses parents
donc vous avez tous intentions vous
trouvez des métiers qu'ils soient qu'ils
ne soient pas les viviers de laquelle on
a vu nos parents de vivre d'une manière
assez pénible et nous on ne voudrait pas
et peu nos parents aussi ne vous
épanouir vivre comme ils ont vécu penser
le problème crucial quoi quand les
immensités quitté la vallée où il
trouver un emploi qui serait assez bon
c'est à dire qu'il ne serait pas basée
sur l'agriculture uniquement un emploi
peut-être un mi-temps avec entre la
station et l'agriculture comment est ce
que tu vois ton avenir à toi ça c'est à
dire mon avenir semble assez bon j'ai
fait que je suis à la faculté je fais
j'étais prêt à regarder la médecine
alors évidemment il ya des problèmes
problèmes d'argent enfin ça c'est arrivé
j'ai une bourse c'est là que les parents
d'auguste habitants l'hiver en été il
habite une maison plus moderne mais en
hiver la vieille demeure et plus
pratique parce que les bêtes qui servent
de chauffage central
[Musique]
lancez vous à prendre avec nous
voilà le maire qui tente un push beurre
rien
les enfants qui déjà pas peur en tout
cas ça coûte
j'ai pas le deal est encore à nos
oreilles vers 17h stone goûter le
fromage c'est vous qui le faites encore
oui
et vous faites moniteur de ski vous êtes
déjà lambertoise manninen m monétaire et
vous me noël
pardon j'ai ici je veux des cours par
correspondance et vous aidez votre mère
à la ferme et les autres qui sont en
trop jeune pour savoir ce qu'ils vont
faire
pourquoi je ne sais quelle météo france
est assez difficile
[Musique]
vous pouvez vous asseoir
pas trop fatiguant à la porte combien de
temps ça dure peut-être une des fois
plus c'est pour faire notre propre peur
oui oui bien sûr on du beurre que vous
vendez dans le bain que je ne sais pas
où j'en fais tous les jours mais trois
ou quatre départs
goûter notre pain et notre beurre
messieurs c'est votre pain oui oui c'est
que je voulais dire vous le faites vous
même
oui bien sûr il ya encore beaucoup de
familles monsieur qui font leur parti ou
très peu très peu ici on n'est pas
beaucoup de monde il y en a qui nous
aide à d'autres villages et des
pratiques non plus quand on est tous là
il faut voir au mois de mai par jour
alors chercher le tournoi alors levé
nouvelle dans la presse et plus
économique
on tourne cette dynamique pour nous
a pas été trop dur d'élever tous ces
enfants monsieur mais aussi sur toi la
campagne la c2 comment êtes vous faire
leurs devoirs
on habitait comme on a pu
surtout maintenant voulait mettre aller
à l'école pour qu'ils aient un métier
convenable par la suite
est-ce que vous pensez que vous allez
essayer de garder vos filles avec vous
ou non
voulez-vous c'est tellement pénible
travail de campagne moi j'aimerais mieux
pour moi qu'elle trouve mêmes faits mais
qui - mais pénible si j'étais jeune à
leur place ben je reconnais je serai
aussi j'aimerais me aller travailler au
d'orb ce qu'il faut connaître le talent
de campagne
c'est très pénible surtout pour une
femme plus pour une femme que pour un
homme riche mais je pense bien oui
vous avez quel âge mais 74 74
c'est quelque chose qu'est ce que vous
pensez de la vie que même aux petites
filles ma votre boutigny espère donc
maintenant je pense qu'elle parle d'une
étude on sait que c'est mieux mais parce
que sa pension l'office vous aviez vous
aviez été à l'école jusqu'à quel âge
même monsieur 14 et ça vous semble pas
quelle impression ça vous fait d'avoir
un fils à l'université j'ai l'impression
en faut bien une bonne impression il
puisse continuer ses études d'aller
jusqu'au bout vous préférez ça plutôt
que de le voir prendre votre succession
à la ferme
oui c'est faire un autre métier que nous
à sa campagne dans la montagne c'est pas
bien un beau métier
vous avez choisir cette profession
particulière du plaisir de la victime
c'est presque un incident quoi il y
avait aucune branche complaisait dans la
dans les lettres ou droit ou sciences
économiques ne plaisait pas du tout par
ses débouchés dans l'administration et
moi je ne vais pas me trouver dans un
bureau pour toute la vie quoi j'ai
rester à une seule une seule manche je
n'avais pas besoin jusqu'à présent
c'était la médecine
j'ai pensé que ma vie comme dactylo un
travail en pouvais y arriver et vous
êtes arrivé je ne sais pas ce qu'ils y
vont le dire à la fin d'année peut-être
j'espère quoi s'est pas prononcé cette
année
évidemment quoi c'est la vie d'étudiant
est plus due aux produits qui dont les
parents sont cultivateurs enfin je crois
qu'on n'y arrive pas c'est pas une
raison pour abandonner
enfin qu'il craque et intimiste
desbuquois enfin si on arrivera
reyes approche de la wii maintenant le
bris change richard jacques ou
sculpteurs et c'est alors on entends ton
d'éleveurs qui respecte il est oui
maintenant lever les freins de berre
généré 12
le premier tronçon du téléphérique
d'orcières merlette la terrasse du bar
restaurant bronzage lunettes noires
couleur rouge
il est impossible de distinguer les
montagnards des citadins j'avais des
contacts avec des tas de deux garçons et
filles qui n'étaient pas dans mon sac
donc qu'il y avait pas eu la même
éducation zhu est ce qu'il ya des
occasions où vous êtes senti différence
et étrangers pour les objets comme vous
les appelez vous même % par exemple on a
des lacunes dans la culture bas dans les
cultures willis ou les loisirs
insuffisant surtout pour les loisirs et
d'icônes à des lacunes dans la culture
monsieur pauvres hères 20 classes comme
eux et moi je vois beaucoup de gars de
la ville qui sont encore plus calme que
nous
[Musique]
on en ville en ville et les gars qui
habitait la ville justement comme disait
non pas parce que vu les variétés par
exemple cinéma les disques et tout mais
j'ai remarqué que les gars de la
montagne qui vont à l'école se sentent
le besoin de se rapprocher des gars de
la ville d'où tendance de travailler
beaucoup plus au lycée pareilles ans et
j'ai remarqué que les gains qu'ils
menaient de la campagne ou de la
montagne était beaucoup plus doués par
exemple enfin doux et travailler
beaucoup plus que ceux de la ville les
garçons de la ville nous prennent un peu
plus simple que ce défi de la ville ils
sont en train de se fier aux apparences
m'en fais quand même
ils nous prennent bien inférieurs aux
cinq ans - ouverte à la dic wwa est ce
que je dis est belle veut dire que les
garçons de la ville quoi qu'à toi une
fille pas un plébiscite wayne filliquet
mcel celle ci aura la huawei à quoi ils
croient que les filles saint martin
c'est un peu le connaissent rien quoi
judicial et an la baisse est tout en bas
je crois non je crois que surtout il ya
la question des traditions
justement les filles de la montagne ou
de la campagne et éduqués sont les
traditions du pays et beaucoup de filles
cachent leur vraie personnalité sous
cette tradition que les à leurs parents
leur laurent priou
mais je crois que réellement les filles
de la campagne sont ciment sup est aussi
bien éduqué je crois que les filles de
la vie mais elles ont plus souci de
rappeler
khadir a tant aimée c'est vrai que celle
que vous allez souci du temps dira-t-on
ben oui ici on n'osera pas ce premier
dernier rue avec un garçon tandis qu'un
ville ils le vendent librement que dans
la campagne parce qu'ici on se connaît
tous
alors les gens disent eh bien voilà ça y
est ça la latte ici où j'arrive on
retient surtout basé sur sap et ses
potes ça nous tient enfin on se cache
plus en nous devons faire ce que tu as
cool pourquoi tu les visuels de
remployer
bien nous avons au moins appris une
chose c'est que la crâne du qu'en
dira-t-on n'empêche pas une belle
lucidité chez les montagnards
elle n'empêche pas non plus de pratiquer
le jerk ses succédanés à condition que
ce soit entre montagnards bien sûr
[Musique]
en
vous êtes vos parents rizon 140 ans ils
ont dû changer eux aussi non mais sans
vouloir porter atteinte à la réducation
certains dans que certificat d'études ou
tout au plus souvent encore s'ils vont
il ne peut pas y avoir de bons rapports
ou de bonnes discussions et discussions
se borne à des discussions de politique
encore parce qu'ils sont au courant un
peu ce qui les intéresse
mais au point de vue science je parle
par exemple aux sciences de l'espace
sont importants on peut pas entretenir
une discussion valable parce que le
manque de niveau se fait sentir entre le
fils qui va à l'école est le parent qui
n'a pas reçu dans sa génération
d'éducation suffisant est ce que tu
dirais l'infection ne compense pas ne
remplace pas si parce que ce qui se
passe c'est que les parents cherchent à
comprendre les risques parce qu'ils
savent tout au moins qu ils en savent
plus que lui un arrêt j'ai dans ma vie
non c'est pas gênant contrat parce qu'on
est toujours s'est satisfait de faire
comprendre quelque chose de ses parents
et de work fois ils sont du muy on peut
on peut un autre tour les éduquer un peu
sur ces questions donc moi je pense
quand même quelque part à on est assez
copain quoi votre travail qui aime bien
et que l'on considère un peu comme les
camarades de travail pas un peu d'image
au bon accueil que l'on rencontre je
prends mon vieux de 50 ans là dans la
rue un beau rappeler que le jeune papa
d'esclaves ils ont ont pas des jeunes
qu'avoir des cafés du coup avec didier
ce soit pas que les vieux ici aiment
bien qu'on leur dise un mot en bateau
par exemple
enfin même qu'on ne sache pas bien par
air france en dix points nectar et je
crois que c'est tout à fait normal parce
que si on ne fait pas ce geste on n'est
plus du pays parce que c'est toujours la
tradition qui revient est toujours fort
et trop simple avec les gars du pays
changer sa personnalité évidemment dû
pousser un peu le truc et je comprends
bien non ce même pas du trucage parce
qu'à la fin on y prend goût
ma précieuse toujours agréable de
discuter avec les vieux de l'entendre
quand et de belles histoires qu'est ce
qu'ils ont vécu toujours embellie bien
sûr mais je crois que non sens on ne
change pas complètement sa personnalité
mais on la transforme sa salle
bonjour
aujourd'hui la procédure
enfin c'est principalement verra plus
tard
bon allez on va
[Musique]